uh-huh back to bat back to back against
FM GM get tasks something okay so he
gotta draw from from the minus a million
position let's see that we don't repeat
this um in this game okay it's usually
pretty weird way of playing it maybe
even Queen t2 now
it's kind of interesting 94 is also good
so what is your move after Queen d2 g5
or what's the deal see just giving you
the porno I don't don't quite see it now
it's giving me the this part okay so
this is again I shouldn't give him a
draw this is again a mind as a million
position yeah a million is a bit bit
strong but it's certainly close to that
how is he not losing now hmm takes on f3
yeah now just 94 i think is strong or
something else yeah i guess just 94 is
good
yeah so um I can take twice on g7 now or
95 it both looks quite strong this one
yeah they both look good so will be
shipped cheeks one night takes a night
eggs he has to play the rook I guess to
e7 maybe
so what to do I can go to e6 on play
Bishop Bishop d3 this may be a form
yeah it's not not super clear
Bishop d3 this is you for more and maybe
at one point he can actually take age 60
okay let's take this first and see now
what to what to do exactly near Bishop
d3 is not completely clear if I cancel
long it's got night before with this
night a tool check III has 95 and I have
to play move ya mean somehow he did not
lose this immediately which probably was
possible it I couldn't find it game
still continues yeah so if I castle long
he's got this a4 move which is quite
quite annoying and 23 is a bit weak
weakening I still have to do it maybe
wow I didn't expect this move at all
okay let's cover this tweenage for this
creature 7 I thought you should be
absolutely happy with the trade
maybe you can actually take it now
hmm I'm really not sure about all this
year that's since I want to simplify
this a little bit with no time check
check check
hmm that's so easy him time warning can
send him back then yeah tricky business
points on both both sides of some wood
week that i didn't expect but ok be 28
Lisa's coming under and the pressure as
well this is threatening mate with Luke
h7 maybe you can I can probably can draw
here with 93 now can draw with my
decision check Jan and probably should
be ok with this my time wasn't great
cause I must win after the opening but i
didn't manage run are dry somehow I
allowed him too much play them yeah and
he apply to adjust wins just wins but I
didn't didn't manage to kill him over 94
this is true this is certainly correct
Bishop d3 now is plus 4 I am yeah this
looked good but maybe it is not so
conclusive I mean bishop age 69 f 7 has
a very clear thing and this is yeah
Bishop d3 is the move you want to play
but it's got before ok the computer is
merciless Bishop before and black resins
this and now here whoops I didn't see
that at the idea
yeah and this is not clear I mean it's
just not a clear position at all after
have missed this opportunity the Queen
age 6 was surprising oh the engine
actually believes he can take it Jeff
Jeff hi this is why I didn't see that
okay so this is actually playable for
black gaming it's probably our about
equal yeah yeah I kind of lost lost
maneuver a little bit Luke h1 given by
the comp yeah that makes sense yeah i
just wanted to simplify started with the
time ticking down jeopardy i'm not
better anymore the engine gives me a
slight edge but it's nothing
particularly great yeah and here
probably i'm lucky that he allowed this
this meeting this meeting idea if he
takes h4 I'm so fighting here my
position here is a little bit
questionable is night it's very nicely
defending and stuff and yeah yeah so I
have to be lucky at the end yeah sure
should end the game out of the open
languid I couldn't find couldn't find
the knockout what was the clearest way
of doing it let's just see probably
probably Bishop d3 here yeah I thought
here but I can bury just go back I can
play without the a1 rook this is too
much I'm threatening even 96 m plus 5 by
the company yeah okay I mean it's not a
big surprise like it's just giving as h6
pawn away and they have the g file open
now but then it's it's a reasonably
trickier one or two stupid moves and
think so yeah things things get
problematic
okay thanks for watching